have you ever wish that you could just
make your own just perfect shade of
lipstick
sounds nice well now you can with the
help of lip
lab they'll have you ready for that
mistletoe moment this holiday season
knock knock hello rocky how are you gosh
i'm good happy to finally be at lip lab
it's so cute in here
thank you we're glad to have you here i
know you had your consultation earlier
with your website
about your pink come over here let's
take a look at how it's going oh my god
look at her mixing it i know
what do you guys do here so it's a
completely customizable experience
we love to have fun here at liplab um
and you have a consultation with your
color expert who creates your custom
shade
you can choose the color a flavor a
finished flavor
flavor girl yes yes and you can also
name it and engrave it
so it's completely customizable okay i
love that you can actually engrave it
and name it because that makes the
perfect holiday gift
absolutely and one really great thing
especially right now this year since um
some families and friends aren't able to
be together
we do also offer virtual consultations
as well as virtual parties oh that's
amazing yeah so everybody can come
together and have that great holiday
spirit and have fun with us here at
liplab
um and who doesn't want a perfectly
customizable
gift for the holidays definitely
customizable gifts are always the best
oh absolutely
unique thoughtful and how do we do the
safety i know you mentioned
party room yeah absolutely so we do have
a party room um
and everything is socially distant as
well as we have limited capacity as well
as plexi glass dividers yeah yeah
in between our guests around yep and
color experts
we thoroughly sanitized before and after
each consultation
um and we are always wearing gloves and
masks perfect
now who can actually come here and enjoy
this experience everyone
anyone five years old 99 years old
man woman anyone i love that okay well
i'm ready to
try my shade yes let's do it have a seat
and i love the fact that it says
all lips have something powerful to say
oh absolutely so i'm ready i know mine
comes out of my mouth in this pink yeah
thank you so much alexis
[Music]
oh my gosh and as you can see our
formulas are very creamy very high
oh that looks really good
i love it it is the perfect pink and the
texture is
incredible i know all of our textures
are super hydrating
and the really great thing is we saved
all your formulas on file it's never
going to be discontinued and you can
always reorder it oh never going to be
discontinued
yes well thank you so much everybody and
happy holidays
so that leads me to my question because
i've had two lipsticks that i just
loved and then they stopped making them
and then that's it i just threw them
away i'm never going to see them again
but
if you do that maybe i wonder if you
could bring an old lipstick and say can
you match this oh i'm sure
right right they're so hip there they've
got to be able to and then what would
your favorite flavor be
denise um probably just something minty
you know just kind of boring but
yeah i don't know what about you
something tropical maybe like chocolate
or eggnog
oh wow okay exotic
the lip lab fashion show mall very cool
still ahead this after